yeah whoo welcome to this broadcast but
it's looking fine I made a slight
adjustment to the cameras set up some of
the background noise seems a little bit
off anyway I think it's totally totally
okay yeah let's get going I haven't
played a single blitz game today so I'm
looking forward to get going in the
five-minute pool yeah and we all know
that the five-minute pool arises see
it's about the toughest opposition that
you can face I am yesterday watch the
video with Maxim loogie playing and he
really got killed in the pool who knows
in like 70 points or so in one session
so tough and blue he is a really great
blitz player yeah hello to all of you
triple checker was Orlando Internet
Chess Club yeah my Ponzi people hello to
all of you yeah my head always look
shiny it's not even well well shaved to
be honest
well shaven what is it shaven but it's
it's about the the camera me yeah
cassoulet
he's playing the night e49 this is an
interesting line that I have not studied
yet I really should do that yeah this is
all five-minute poor my rating is
currently not very high I usually am on
the 2400 range but I didn't play that
well recent game so I'm a bit low
yeah playing castle a very high rated
French I am do I go 95 here maybe 95
Sarah one in Kawana playing okay maybe
we are lucky and we get we I get the
chance to play them would be would be
nice my score gives yes it's not that
bad I've won a couple of games over the
years but Caruana
I only beat once and lost tons of times
he's just yeah obviously very good
so um f6 hmm yeah for Queen deform I
think I have for how many dreams do you
think you would have to buy cars and to
make it an even game oh it's difficult
to say he doesn't seem to be the type to
drink alcohol at all to be honest so
maybe it doesn't need that much to get
into into trouble I mean it's a it's a
very very substantial mismatch so hard
to tell really but I feel it's not yeah
he probably don't need much doesn't need
much to to be out of out of shape I mean
I'm not a huge drinker but I can do to
my pure um yeah due to my weight I can I
can drink a little bit without being it
too too terrible
okay so Queen jh5 someone said this is a
nice handle for a French guy I don't
know what cassoulet means can you can
you translate please my French knowledge
is basically not existing non-existent
it's the right way to put it okay I have
absolutely no knowledge of the french
language so um bishop will come to g6 I
guess mmm
you play very quickly yeah if I could
trade Queens that would be nice but I
don't see how it's probably quite draw
position
I get some activity here maybe g3 does
Queen f3 yeah maybe this one a French
speciality with beans or how interesting
beans is not very common part of the
French of the French foods what what am
I doing here why did I go there he's
threatening queenie one now that was
that was rather stupid and maybe I can
still draw with Queen g5 here
very stupid that allowed this my place
super quickly it's playing very quickly
the sky you know I cannot go Queen the
aid now unfortunately I can check here
but that doesn't help a lot and it was a
very stupid way of playing G flawless
was just bad that's going bishop before
now and now I have got huge problems him
I cannot move wow that was really really
bad bit of a shame I usually score very
well against him even though is higher
rated okay g4 was a challenge Wow
yeah g4 was terrible okay let's see what
we can do in the next game mobi oh okay
so we got a scotch game we're playing my
usual line what is this is this a new
handle for my way or so said some kind
of Norwegian special special speciality
cheerio to Vienna back yeah I never
understand why people would play such an
opening moving the night thousand times
but it is it is some quite surprisingly
not immediately lost for white it looks
terrible but it is still not lost
he has to play queen er3 now I guess g3
24 is pretty embarrassing yeah so what
do we do rook e8 I guess so Knight f6
494 can also check f2 but Knight f6
looks good
the world champion in drunk chess
difficult difficult but definitely not
me but there are a couple of notorious I
mean some people are pretty well known
even even some grandmasters for being
able to drink quite quite huge amounts
of alcohol and still yeah playing
playing okay so wait what a weird
position
can you still play this should be to
here probably yes if it takes 90 X 90 f2
looks pretty yeah to catch EFS it's an
Internet aureus but I think he got it
feels like he got a little bit more
solid recently I once played the final
stages of the Dutch team championships
met Takashi F was playing and he spent
the whole night before the final match
when steam was competing for the Dutch
Team Championships in the karaoke bar
that was funny I wasn't I wasn't around
but it was supposed to be a legendary
yeah some friends of mine were around
and they said they have never
experienced anything like that no one
ever never chest while intoxicated or
even close to that
yeah I'm threatening Knight f2 and I'm
threatening
here on on stuttering the bishop there
so I don't think he can defend this at
least I don't see
yeah here I was thinkin maybe age six
seven - yeah age six mix quite some
sense or f6 I have six bishops you four
so go age six first get some room for
the king
yeah I like different different types of
beer released I have no particular
preference I like I didn't miss a fork I
I thought that just this is the better
way of walking you can't argue of course
if I'm right with that but if help this
is better okay so how to do that now
activate the king
I like Guinness on the like if you want
a somewhat darker beer and recently I
enjoy pure that walk when a lot which I
recently promoted not not like actively
endorsed by the brewery but on my
3-minute madness video where I had a
pillow that work well the most beautiful
chess game in history tough I know it's
funny because I'm a I'm a Rubenstein fan
but I think it's really what lady
Rubinstein this is such just so
beautiful that that combination that
kuben Stein got in there with the super
spectacular series of sacrifices it was
just fantastic ok so how do I play this
I think you look here should be good and
let's let's activate stuff now rook
takes rook g3 is pretty straightforward
and here I should be able to also
activate enough that I get the H pawn
yeah I think I mean there have there are
legendary reports by drunk play by
various people I mean tile for sure
wrote levy Rubinstein this is this is
the game that I was referring
- so mmm I didn't allow him to much
counterplay here
Brooke edge walking c4 h5 King c5 and
rook on the six okay oh I miscounted
this move that's not good hmm I played
that badly I was thinking I'm just in
time to get the rook on the sixth rank
but I'm not very bad
ah what have I done to deserve this no
no I blunder in the rook oh my god oh
wow oh I have to really get my game
together here from that position Wow Wow
now oh camon yeah I didn't even have the
chance to play any warm-up games that
probably tells okay let's see if I can
win this game playing against the
teammate of mine yeah that's always the
same stuff well that's not very exciting
the London system
yeah I I don't think that I can can
explain that what the poodle scared is
the literal translation would be the
core of the poodle which is better funny
is it from this from goethe's faust
right yeah
well that last game that was really a
shame from that completely winning
position losing Wow
yeah it's a kind of nothing happens
position I'm kind of surprised that he
played this opening yeah it does yeah it
means getting to the point that's a good
translation but we just wants to trade
the whole the whole house iam okay now I
didn't didn't didn't play any fallout
for yet
I just watched some some let's play
videos and I have to admit it looks
interesting even though I'm not as I
said before I'm not a huge fan of the of
this kind of yeah post-nuclear scenarios
the watching what a saw looks a little
bit like it looks a little bit like yeah
how do you call it what is it and the
walking dead yeah with the this zombie
like creatures running around before
surprised me I get some playing and see
three now not sure I've it's multiplayer
I like a Mediterranean food quite a bit
Greek things or Italian but I'm pretty
open to to new things now
so he still has this somewhat weakest
pawn them it's still so quite you always
short course
it's pretty Jewish yeah it's it's this
game the fallout for it has quite a bit
of building building things but sure
before I was considering g5 earlier but
I wasn't sure if this is this is any
good
yeah grinding a wind out of that it's
not easy can tell you I know my opponent
he's a very good endgame player so
trying to get active here with the
bishop it's going bishops if - probably
and it's annoying
it's still quite George I think it's
hard to get anywhere
ah thanks for buying my book hope you
enjoy it yeah that's a kindle version
out now that's it's good now I won't do
I want to do an ollie gasp yeah
I don't tend to do that anyway and a
special note especially not against
teammates of mine and I didn't play The
Witcher I somehow I didn't like that in
that interface so much cannot really
tell you why I have no clear explanation
why but I didn't like it so much
somehow I have a soft spot for the Elder
Scrolls so what did you know maybe f-5e
force oh yeah doing a game review with
my widow with a wooden chess board I
never thought about that it's an
interesting way to do things I saw that
John did that but I think he did it
mostly out of necessity not because it
felt like a particularly great idea I
mean it's it's okay I'm not saying it's
bad but so what happens here
can I keep can I keep active here with
my rook
hmm that's probably a draw anyway I
don't see a way to win this position and
anyway hmm my rookie sixes a weird move
actually
but I didn't didn't want to trade
and is getting b5 very likely oh I see
Syd doubling my feet to I don't think he
can double I forgot about that one
that's a good move okay now I can cover
b5 though see out for Luke c5 oh I don't
know
okay I think I have to hmm
played that well I've got slight issues
here with the drawn
I think you offered me at wrong yeah of
course I would take that yep okay draw a
grid I think it is a draw
I think I'm active enough that I can go
around but I can always defend that okay
so I'm on the scoreboard at least with a
with a draw so let's see I'm playing the
South toll or something and I really
want to win now Bishop f5 that's a weird
move actually whose Vidocq that's ball
scratch chef yeah I'm a checking two
points here okay so how do I go about it
Bishop f4 this is something and it looks
a lot like the slab exchanged with some
extra extra moves thing is why this
looks very good it is not a direct win
or anything it's just noise yeah well as
I already answered that with the with
the the real board I don't think that it
helps a lot I mean it's okay as I said
but i don't i don't consider doing that
no so just normal mu sim
yeah I tried to get that book decomposed
master - ah but it's out of print you're
not so easy to get you can only get it
from some used bookstore use books
bookstore or something I'm kind of
screwing this up it's not like available
in regular in regular stores on Amazon
for that matter I I don't have any pets
no I like cats if you want what I want
kill the cats or door crashing but I
don't have a cat so I'm going to go 46
entering here and playing on the see
file that's my kind of position looks
very very nice like has zero play Queen
be five maybe was force more incisive
I'm taking this yes John Gustafson says
in his dreams gimme gimme gimme
this is this is from other right gimme
gimme gimme yeah and I agree I want to
take stuff if they give me stuff I take
it yeah the cat worthless cucumbers this
is this is crazy right but you shouldn't
do that to your cats
oh he resigned I think if you have a cat
don't do the cucumber trick it seems
awful for the cat they are really
awfully afraid of cucumbers
no the internet chess club account is
maintained by the admin and they look
for me and they look for a lookout for
bettering better language and stuff like
that so be aware no bad language on the
stream so I got a win in here let's see
what I can do against Panther warrior I
go for one year for now is that our song
give me give me give me a man after
midnight the depth that's really in the
text right I never really put any
thought into it because otherwise
normally not my kind of music
and but it really it is it really is the
text of idiom okay so that looks kind of
nice actually
my tg5 maybe looks good yeah time for
bends I think so do I want to play g4
here I mean the question I want let's do
that I'm a natural optimist so I'm not
I'm not really I mean I agree that
currently the world situation looks kind
of bad but I mean what can you do it's
just just what it is
yeah I'm a bit surprised that he takes
time here that looks very normal that
move so I have three I guess or Luke Ji
Won
let's go where three can someone I can
also know I cannot bear can someone been
are a RJ somebody please
so what about this position hmm hmm it
looks 96
sorry my voice is failing me 96 is a
good move I didn't think of that
okay let's go down yeah I've given up a
pawn I pretty much think I had to but I
hope that I have some compensation
there's always hope d7 was covered now
because Dickens is not that this is not
something that should be bandits from
Monty Pyatt Android Life of Brian he
plays well that Panther warrior what the
beep
give me give me give me a man after
midnight I can't get my head around
around that that is really the text
right well other really had terrible
tech front terrible lyrics I mean money
money money must be funny and that was
so cool so so out for Ruchi for if I
would be cute DVD of my book hmm not not
planned
yeah Ruchi for at least looks like some
kind of idea so I was going back there
and what now see for whom
yeah I'm still not threatening much this
is the worst part
second rook to g3 to h3 that looks kind
of crazy c4 I can take I believe yeah
other a super cat serum so they were a
little bit before my time but my parents
will love them so I'm kind of yeah what
can you do
yeah I can take this and I think I will
these can activate now with with rook
rook checks and stuff but I got my pawn
back at least yeah goodbye hunter skin
tears yeah now I can draw and I think I
will actually I don't see a huge point
and not drawing here it's wrong that's
just a joy yeah not what not much to do
I mean 41 so when have a split I was
like was like a little child let's say
okay so maybe here Kings Indian Kings
Indian often leads to nice sharp games
hmm we should be to us a bit uncommon in
this kind of position no I'm not I'm not
really shooting for the GM title simply
have no time to to to study enough
yeah this looks active right mate age
four okay going back
is he threatening to take on fire I
don't think so
when I 5 I mean
and white is castling long let's sure
I'm not quite sure what he tried but
looks kind of wrong but I mean it's
probably not like wrong wrong wrong but
it's a little bit off
yeah if he takes that five I think I can
take I can take d5 I dare Bishop f5 2594
I guess yeah he's taking ages I ideas 94
here Wow he did take it i I really don't
think it works oh I see I can maybe
sacrifice the Queen in this position
Queenie form that looks somewhat
playable yeah he had to do that so let's
pry open this position as quickly as
possible
96 Queen g6 Wow he cancelled long short
short I mean
yeah this is I mean it's probably not
enough compensation but it's for blitz
chess this is still kind of tricky
I'm not quite sure if he keeps this
material now wow that's an interesting
and he threatening 95 funny enough
Wow
hmm I'm not quite sure what I should
play it's a bit strange this position I
think I should go out of that take age
three
yeah maybe 95 looks very sharp but maybe
that's the right move
of course I didn't see that coming I
really wonder sometimes how some some
players start with like blundering the
house and then they play great moves all
the time
it's remarkable sometimes
and ig5 look at form maybe I'm just
about holding here but it looks awful
okay at least he didn't shred my queen
okay let's get rid of the bishop there
and then hopefully Queen III one day
okay a cheeks Knight X Knight will come
to a fire unfortunately
tough
I'm actually a fairly decently practical
player it just said I often don't
understand why people play sometimes
very obvious bad moves and then good
moves they then they can easily play
here again Bishop d2 was very strong
idea and he played that merely and he
played the opening just terribly bad Wow
I only have six seconds unfortunately
yeah Wow I don't know very very strange
game he blundered the Queen but he got
excellent compensation for that I don't
know how that worked
okay so playing sv me I love him I
really don't want to use reading from
2300 no no my opponent was a human being
of course it wasn't the cheetah at all I
just played like a [ __ ] so let's see
you back into something against mr.
mayor I love him
I'm just transporting back to a regular
Kings Indian I'm fine with that so okay
I want some some peace and quiet after
that game grinding this end game
look if I broke the age I'll get the
piece back
he cannot take if also I'm a pawn up but
he black has very decent compensation of
course a bishop before was pretty normal
no no I have to add to play better
before coordinating my my pieces better
yeah this is not easy I'm a pawn up but
black has a fairly active position it's
not full compensation for him but it's
something that it's not
not easier so for me to play let's see
rook d1 does not work right a5 probably
okay this is difficult to win definitely
I had those and those end games before
okay that is easy to win
if they give me a night I'm winning this
end game against me hi love I had 9 out
of 10 so against some people you just
score well then did some against some
you do absolutely nothing he didn't have
full compensation for the pawn but it's
difficult to win this end game because
white structure is so awful the pawn is
nice but it's a yeah it's hard to win
yeah I'm requesting a new game don't get
one yet let's at least get above 2300
below feels wrong
do I have to sing about songs to get a
new opponent
don't don't don't let it come to that
get no game you see Evelyn oh yeah
no games what the heck here's again turn
to turned one okay so before age five
can we have some funny
let's go a five year against the sky
trying to be mean to the guy three
hundred points lower but can easily
backfire
I'm trying to play quickly yeah I get
like 1 or 2 rating points and that's
probably right in case of a win oh my
was yeah
one day of chess teaching really kills
your voice like to take the night before
it arrives on d5
have you ever gotten a nice beating by a
sub 1800 in on the ICC probably I mean
you don't get 18 hundredths often with
with that kind of raiding in in
tournament chess like three years ago I
played to draw against someone rated
1700 and he had a winning position at
the end I offered the draw though and I
mean it was my it was not like he had
PNX tupiza so he had an excellent
endgame and I've really felt like I'm
completely out of ideas so I offered the
draw and I was lucky that he accepted it
um yeah he played a fantastic game
sometimes it happens
being a clearly lower rated does not
mean that you have to play bad moves all
the time and in that case he played yeah
excellently well okay I'm trying to
block the queenside him where to see
getting it I am
right a six-night f-4s my idea is maybe
angling for 93 jf5 that's an interesting
interesting line
I think I can after the trade Knight f5
can go night g7 I don't place card no I
don't play any card game on a decent
level
I mean poker I can play Hold'em on a
decent level at least I could a while
ago but haven't played for a long time
and Scott is something I mean I know the
rules and I can't play but I'm not good
yeah this position it looks a bit shaky
for black but the thing is if I can get
if I am not getting made it or anything
on my somewhat exposed King I'm just
winning with the structure and now with
the pawn
okay I'm going to open now the G file
trying to attack myself
interesting c5 yeah I know reason not to
take yeah there are a couple of other
interesting games someone mentioned to
go yeah it's supposed to be very
interesting British also but it's
something that I never I never really
felt the urge to take up seriously
always fell to have my hands full with
chess yeah now 24 is just a queen trait
I'm attacking the bishop on h4 and the
Queen so he has to trade Queens and I'm
two points up if I'm not mistaken likely
winning another one
yeah I'm above 2,300 actually oh okay so
one more game see if I can keep that
rating keep that rating against Park
Park our Park hooah I know yeah good
question but salvia divinorum who is
chess being my job what is my hobby yeah
it's a bit difficult actually maybe I
should pick up something that I can do
but not at the moment I'm just doing
chest chest chest it's a little bit
sorry it's a little bit much actually I
should I should maybe pick up some
physical sport but currently not quite
sure what that might be okay what is he
doing here shooting for b5 they really
just play the first move that comes to
mind give up give up the bishop pair get
a bad pawn structure everything at once
okay so mmm okay I'm taking this until
95 difficult now for him to avoid this
bad pawn structure with Knight takes f6
learning instrument yeah that's a funny
idea I I would really love to be able to
play some kind of music but I think I'm
immensely non talented for that so how
to do that Bishop g5 put more pressure
on him he's got the worst structure ever
cannot ever bet close
I was thinking Bishop e6 could be simple
solution here now let's do this first
now there are no mountains in my area
now that's a nice position I would like
to get somewhere here there should be
six he had rook takes c6 intermediate
move
Wow really okay
Queen age six that looks kind of awful I
mean really II 6 f 6 g 6 that's how you
play okay that's made on f7 or where
somewhere yeah yeah I'm walking my
current I could I started my fitness
program also with walking a lot and it
really paid off I'm just I'm just much
much fitter physically than a couple of
months ago I think I'm going for one
more game yeah just one more yeah doing
revenues on razors we could do that
I tried quite a couple for my for my
head but the best thing to say are the
most useful advice for raises to use
them often you can easily sharpen your
razor yourself with a piece of leather
or even with your own own skin so even
if you buy super expensive razors and
most of them are very expensive you can
easily use them for a long time not only
like 5 or 10 times you can you can
easily use them like for 4 weeks and
month so on something very interesting
that I that I learned
it's a bit strange Age 3 and we should
be to combined
so he's got somewhat strange setup there
with the bishop on f3 but it's not it's
not terrible or anything so let's see
what to do now she's six mmm leading
nowhere I guess
now you can sharpen and erase us with
with pieces of leather that's that's the
easiest way to do it
I make crazy moves and I'm playing good
moves I think sometimes at least isn't
lightly for working here no it's not a
94 Bishop d8 92 rupee 8 who okay I'm I'm
a coffee guy not a tea guy yeah I'm not
a huge expert on the Kings Indian and
it's somehow it's somehow shoes that
looks bad
do you think that watching streams like
this helps in improving who not a lot to
be honest I think it it's not bad to
look at
relatively our decent players and what
is he doing what that is crazy night at
5:00 or so it does it does help I think
a little bit but it's not the most
useful training experience of course I
mean studying I don't know
endings looking at master games in books
or whatever is certainly more useful but
I think it's a good way of combining
some entertainment
with them with learning stuff so not bad
at all I mean I watch stuff like this
myself I watch what Maxime Doogie is
doing he's basically doing a similar
show that I'm doing it's on I think on
Wednesdays on the on the same twitch
channel as here and watch Greg show
what's called crack crack goes to the
pool or so it's it's nice you get to see
a good players player player play games
and you're you take the odd idea yeah
and this can be in openings that can be
middle games or whatever are you just
just learn stuff and it's an Intendant
it is in a bow it is in an entertaining
way kind of twisting my tongue ham yeah
and my queen is just taking stuff his
capture on f6 was a very strange move
hmm what is he shooting for oxy to 1 mm
I don't have many squares to be honest
maybe I have to do this
secure the a 3 square as a question what
should one look for in a chess coach
yeah that's tough to answer I mean I'm a
chess teacher myself so I could easily
easily say oh just just hire me but that
would be a bit cheap
okay so I'm just keeping my material
here and go from there
so what to do politics maybe that look
strong I mean it both look strong but
he's got a tough time now against all my
opponents there be five I can also do
this this first I've got quite a number
of strong points there on the queenside
yeah I like a Coby ins a Cobian some
lectures is doing a good job buddy they
have a couple of good lecturers there so
taking this
and now drive the pawns home
yes somebody asked me about teaching yes
sir sure I said sent me a message and we
can ask her we can talk about lessons
okay hey - I don't ask about my camera
it's not a good idea I have no
particular plans to visiting the United
States I mean I would love to I would
really love to but the issue is I really
hate flying absolutely do and if I would
go to the United States it is a six
seven-hour flight at least and the only
way I have a do that is for a longer
vacation like I do like four weeks or
something and this is pretty costly and
tough too tough to organize so I'm not
yeah not not really having anything
planned like that okay we have like 10
or 11 minutes past 11:00 my time and I'm
finishing my my day of work here hope
you enjoyed the show I won a couple of
points at the end at least got a couple
of wins and started off really badly but
I kind of got into stride later okay I
hope you enjoyed it and I'll be back
next next week
next Monday thanks guys